Oprah Winfrey Elon Musk Steve Jobs these
are some of the largest personal brands
in human history in terms of name
recognition and their global impact
they've all built multiple brands but
it's their personal brand that we
remember now imagine you walking through
a grocery store and having someone come
up to you and say I saw you on YouTube
and your video changed my life
that is personal branding people start
to know you personally rather than the
products and the services that you sell
remember
people want to do business with people
and right now with all of the digital
tools at your fingertips there's no
better time to go all-in on personal
branding but you're probably asking well
how do I even get started with a
personal brand in this episode Sean sits
down with Chris Ducker who's a number
one best-selling author and the creator
of you preneur he is the leading expert
when it comes to understanding the
three-step process to creating a
powerful and effective personal brand
and he's breaking down each step for you
so you can get clear on what your next
move is and make sure you stick around
until the end where Chris shares the no
miss way to making money right now with
your personal brand also if you know a
business owner in your life who needs to
hear this make sure to share it with
them
welcome to the big marketing podcast the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean kennel
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you hey
welcome back to the think marketing
podcast Sean kennel here and I'm sitting
with Chris Ducker I'm fired up to have
him on the show author of the rise of
the you preneur serial entrepreneur runs
multiple different businesses over 300
different team members and really is
powerful at helping us as business
owners and entrepreneurs develop a
powerful personal brand and monetize it
and that's what we're gonna be talking
about in this session but yes not only
am i fired up that's shown on the think
marketing podcast I'm fired up that
you're speaking at grow with video live
this year in September and we'll talk
about that later
yep but for those that are just meeting
you man what's kind of your backstory in
business and entrepreneurship and and
kind of how you help people man how long
you go you know I often say that
honestly at the very core of what I do
I'm just a sales guy genuinely like you
know my entire world in terms of my
career has been around sales and
marketing ever since I was 17 years old
at my first telemarketing job and you
know from there I've worked with large
teams small teams I've been an
entrepreneur for 15 years we've built
several different businesses a couple
which have flopped horrific Lee and some
of them have done very very well indeed
and so now what I focus on is helping
people build businesses future-proof
businesses profitable businesses based
around their personal brands and really
what they love doing and what they're
great at doing
yeah I'm fired up about this topic and
first of all to get into it I want to
talk to kind of two different types of
people in the think community on the one
hand we've got people that are already
kind of clear on the fact that they
want to tap into being a thought leader
an author or speaker maybe create
courses turn their knowledge into a
business and so they're already kind of
there but then we also have this whole
community of business owners that are
realizing that as a business owner
they've got their thing they might even
be brick and mortar but that they're
like men do I need to build a personal
brand is this social media thing for me
different than just putting up an
account for my business for my local
shop format for me as a real estate
agent so let's just kind of unpacked why
personal branding and why does it matter
to the think community look at the end
of the day we all have a personal brand
it's called our reputation that's just
fact whether you identify with it as a
personal brand is obviously something
we've got to work on right the reason
why it's important is because I believe
at this point in history we are more
likely way more turned on our more
excited and more fired up about working
with other people
more so than ever before in the history
of the world plain simple people want to
do business with other people we don't
necessarily want to do business with big
brands actually some of us don't have a
problem doing it but do we really like
the human connection I think is being
you know the thirst for that human
connection is deeper than it's ever been
before because here we are in a very
hyper connected world more so than ever
yet we've never been more disconnected
as a human race yeah and I think that in
itself
screams personal branding screams
relationship building and relationships
of the single most important thing in
business in life period so if you were
sitting down a kitchen table talk not
classroom not you know someone who's
just getting into this idea of personal
branding what do you think that means in
the first actions like how could someone
do an audit if they're saying okay well
do I have a personal brand I mean I know
it's my reputation but let's talk about
online yeah what's sort of the lens that
you'd be thinking about for getting your
personal brand in order well first and
foremost you've got to figure out who
you are and what you want to be known
for like that's key because it all
begins with that one thing so you've got
to define
who you are playing simple so the three
big questions number one Who am I I what
am I good at secondly what do I actually
want to be known for that's a big one
yeah because you might be really good at
something but you might not actually
want to be known for it is something
else right something you're passionate
about something that you kind of good at
but you need to work on a little bit
more and then lastly not to get too deep
or too rah-rah it's legacy you know what
do you want to be remembered for and
this is just very you know like super
recent you know news and history with
the death of Kobe Bryant and Here I am
sitting here as a Celtics fan given a
Laker all the love in the world as a
father I knew he had kids but I it's sad
to a certain degree he passes away at a
very very young age yet we don't really
get to know the man until he's no longer
with us so he might be known for his
accomplishments on the basketball court
but will he be remembered just as a
basketball player
no he'll be remembered as a dad and was
a husband philanthropist and somebody
who wanted to help girls sports and all
that kind of stuff so it can get quite
deep you know like you can go as deep as
you want to go with it
but really it the first step Shaun if
you don't know who you are and what you
want to be known for that's the end of
the journey right there you've got to
figure out what you want to be known for
and how to define yourself that's
powerful and I love also that you
ultimately bring it to legacy that's one
of the huge values of our event of our
company where we want to be that we've
realized we think we're in the biggest
era to impact others totally which it's
just the Internet it's social media it's
the fact of interconnectivity that we
have opportunities now that just didn't
exist before and we're seeing it happen
I mean a million subscribers on take
media I'm a small town kid through
that's rocket haulage draw love that
started shooting videos in my bedroom
we're connected were connected if you're
listening to this working it I mean
because of social media podcasting
YouTube so what's really step two though
once you've got that kind of dialed in
what do you want to do next to establish
your personal brand maybe picking
platforms is that where you go
there's another step before this step
before that as well so step number two
is to figure out who you want to serve
so now you figured out who I am what I
want to be known for step two figure out
who I'm gonna serve so who's your
perfect customer who's your perfect
Abbot are to use a core trendy word
right ultimately it's your perfect
customer because yes we want to serve
people we want to help people we want to
inspire and motivate people but we're
building a business right we need to
make money as well so it's a perfect
customer is what it is not an advertiser
customers yeah and you've got to build
that out what problems are they having
that I got solutions for or can create
solutions for number two what questions
roll around in their head when they
trying to go to sleep at night that they
need answers to that I've got I'm gonna
serve those answers up and once you know
what's going on in regards to those two
things right there you can figure out
who that perfect kiss that that perfect
customer is and then it goes on to step
three step three bow homes how I'm gonna
reach them where are they gonna find me
what am I gonna do to turn them on how
you know give me a reason to become
somebody's favorite yeah that's the big
one right there and that makes sense
because once you know who you're trying
to reach now you want to pick the best
platforms to read that reach that type
of person it makes everything so much
easier when you know who you're talking
to your messaging your verbage all of
your marketing copy this just even
actually the way your website looks the
type of logo you have once you know who
you're serving everything becomes so
much easier and why why swim against the
current unless you really need to right
yes so you know now we're kind of I was
literally just doing a coaching session
with twenty thirty people just an hour
ago and the big question was like whoa
there was a lady there who is involved
in t-shirt printing in apparel for
Millennials where do I go to hang out I
said Instagram and YouTube that's where
the Millennials are hanging out so
similar that oh you don't think LinkedIn
was like t-shirts on LinkedIn sure you
know what I mean yeah so I think it
really comes down to what you're gonna
be known for who are you gonna be
serving and where they're hanging out
and once you figure that out you
do likewise in celebration of the launch
of this brand-new podcast we're giving
away two tickets to our annual
conference grow as video live a $1,500
value all you have to do to enter is
make sure you subscribe leave us a
review on Apple podcast and then take a
screenshot of your review and go to
think marketing show.com for the rest of
the details super super powerful and I'm
excited to get into some tips of maybe
what you see is the opportunity now to
get some of those views or to get some
of those hot things that maybe you're
doing in your own business but I want to
remind you Chris is speaking at grow
with video live 20/20 grow with video
live.com if you haven't got your tickets
yet you're not gonna want to miss this
event a speaker lineup is insane so go
to grow with video live.com to see
everyone who is coming three days and
it's really gonna be all about every
aspect of video because I really believe
video is now cross-platform video is put
people's preferred content format of
choice yes LinkedIn has video YouTube
has video course live streaming on
Twitch but Instagram has video Facebook
has stories and live streaming and video
and so we're gonna be talking about
video whether it's the tech side whether
it's the scripting your videos what
should you say in your content and
psychology side we're gonna be talking
about the technical side how do you rank
your videos you know and and SEO and we
have guest speakers that are doing video
on so many different platforms in so
many different ways what kind of
tactical things are you up to right now
maybe just in your own business I know
you're taking YouTube seriously and then
you know I mean I should say I'm excited
about going to this event for myself
like just for selfish reasons right now
because you know I've been on YouTube
for a decade but I haven't genuinely
taken it all that seriously up until
maybe just a few months ago genuinely
yeah it was kind of like it was like the
video graveyard where we were just kind
of dump stuff that we wanted to kind of
embed elsewhere kind of thing yeah and
now we're taking it much more see and
you know it it comes with no shock to
the system to know that with that added
focus that we've unleashed onto the
channel
since the beginning of this year more
subscribers and ever before more views
and ever before
we've even got older videos with
affiliate links in the descriptions that
are making us money now for the first
time in like years because they've been
reactivated by the new action that
you're doing on the exactly so I'm
excited to come to the event just to
hang out learn myself it'll be a
pleasure to speak don't get me wrong but
I'm coming to learn as well but I think
you know for me the big thing for me is
that you know it also comes down to the
repurposing side of things because it's
very very very hard to be everywhere all
the time
right if you start with video however
everything from there becomes easier you
can rip the audio out and turn it into
an audio podcast you can you know rip
certain sections out of the video two
minutes here a minute there three
seconds there and share them all over
social and it's about spreading your
message at the under at the end of the
day you might be interesting sitting
down and watching a 45 minute chat with
me on how I built multiple businesses
but there might be somebody else out
there that just needs two minutes of
content from me to light the fire under
their bottom that they need to be able
to go ahead and do what they need to do
to take things to the next level
everyone's different and that's why I
love videos of format is because you can
chop and change it in so many different
ways turn it into an infographic done
turn it into a blog post done turn it
into a slide deck you know I've done
there's so many different options with
it and I think that's why it's so
exciting it's a very very exciting time
and it's not even the topic of today's
conversation but no when you get into
repurposing or going multi-platform you
come into the quandary of well how am I
gonna sustain that myself and you're the
expert on virtual staffing right you
wrote the book virtual freedom yes and
so of course check out the description
below the rise the you preneur virtual
freedom like your resources are all-time
in world-class and so anyways we're not
gonna get into that now that's why you
got to come to grow a video because it's
not 2 3 & 4
you need help like yeah you take that
top of if you will
pyramid kind of content that then
trickles down who's editing that and
those types of things but I want to talk
about next a monetization because I
think there's the power
with personal branding not just to grow
your existing business when you have a
powerful personal brand you're gonna get
more clients customers you're gonna have
more goodwill business is done with
people who know like and trust you so
when you have a strong personal brand no
matter what your business is it's gonna
help but the power of the arrow we're
living in is you can also monetize your
personal brand in multiple ways what are
some of the things and opportunities
that exist for us as we build our yeah I
mean like here's the thing there are you
know way more opportunities today to
monetize our expertise and we've ever
had before at the very very easiest way
to be able to do it is about picking
that low-hanging fruit of coaching and
consulting now it's not the most
scalable model obviously right but the
fact of the matter is that there are
people out there that will be more than
happy to pay to access your experience
download it from your brain and put it
into this to fast-track their own
journey so coaching consulting not
scalable no but a great way to stop
monetizing pretty much out of the gate
because if you're an expert in something
doesn't matter what it is let's say for
example you're you know you've been on
LinkedIn for 15 years and you've been
helping people build out their LinkedIn
profiles and their presence on LinkedIn
you're an expert on LinkedIn there are
people who'd be happy to pay five six
seven hundred bucks an hour you know sit
with you to learn how to do that to
further their careers see it 15 years
compressed into 50 minutes absolutely
that's what it's about
so coaching and consulting number one
lowest-hanging monetization fruit
hands-down secondly if you're an expert
the chances are you're creating content
to prove that right to build your a
tribe to build your community to spread
your message so obviously with a little
bit of luck you're being smart and
building an email list along the same
time affiliate marketing drop some of
those affiliate links you do this
beautifully yourself drop some of those
affiliate links to gear or to services
or products be careful not to do it just
tap anything obviously a little
integrity will go a long way but if you
utilize the product before or you enjoy
a service that you use regularly you can
easily drop that in there talk about it
talk about the benefits of using that
product or service and people because
they trust you as you said they're more
likely to click on that
that you've provided them and by through
you than they are just to go to Amazon
and search for it randomly right number
three we keep going here
number three is really digital content
this is where it does get very scalable
because you create an online course once
as you well know and you sell it over
and over and over and over again now
whether it's a mini course kind of like
an entry level type product five videos
500 bucks or whether it's a flagship
course of you know 20 different videos
and modules printouts and all the rest
of it the two grand or something it
doesn't really matter what it is gonna
be anything in between any of that but
the fact is this is experience
this is know-how these are tips tactics
strategies that really work for the
people that you're wanting to inspire
and help and you put that into a digital
format and ultimately turn that into an
online course and you sell it all day
long that's truly scalable every
personal brand entrepreneur better have
an online course because there are going
to be probably a good 20 to 25 percent
of the people that come into contact
with them are gonna be right to buy that
course at some point in their journey
yeah and hear it think marketing podcast
is one of the things were the biggest
fan of I mean the e-learning industry
yeah and there's of course the article
by Forbes that by 2025 it's gonna be
nearly a billion dollar a day industry
what is the day when I saw that
statistic I almost spat out my coffee
right wouldn't believe a day and that's
that's what we're looking at over the
next five years we're looking at over
this opportunity that people are now
realizing that education is being
flipped upside down it's being
decentralized and we're empowered as
individuals to help people with what
we've learned help them learn from our
mistakes help them go further faster
package our in our knowledge into a
digital course and it's one of our
favorite ways to monetize because of
there's all the perks I mean even you're
not shipping or returning anything so
you don't have a garage full of books oh
good or products that of man you you
know malfunction and you have to worry
about a shipping container from China
that just has some moisture in it or
something
refunds are easy to do and and
interaction you know it's digital not to
mention the fact though from the person
who buys the call
it's digital they can access it anywhere
in the world on any device they can
watch it when they're running it you
know aeroplane or traveling by train get
it inside for shipping yep yep
yes it's huge there's so many benefits
and perks and it's and it's just one of
the income streams you know one of our
community members in our inner circle
program where we talk a lot about how to
build an online course is McCain dogs
big YouTube channel helping people to
get their dogs to sit heel stop peeing
on the carpet I need them to come to my
house they they've got 70 employees
they've got a were there locally
training dogs but they've also then
packaged their expertise in an online
course which is just another income
stream and something that they can
continue to scale up to give them either
more profitability more impact global
reach and so it is our belief we agree
with you 100% that every single personal
brand business owners should highly
consider creating a digital course of
their knowledge and expertise absolutely
you know it and it really just comes it
like people overthink this so much and
it really comes down to just surveying
your audience find out where the pain
points are ask one very simple question
what are you struggling with right now
looking at the information cuz that's an
open-ended question that's not a
closed-ended yes/no tomorrow today
Monday Tuesday type question that's an
open-ended question I open-ended
questions I open up the floodgates to
information once you've got information
as we all know is one of the most
valuable commodities on the planet you
can genuinely go ahead you take that
information to one side and you can
figure out how to best solve that
problem for that person and at the very
core of what we do is entrepreneurs its
content creators as people that we you
know genuinely want to inspire and help
other people out there the core at the
very core of what we do we're just
problem solvers don't have any delusions
of grandeur that's all we're really
doing that's it solving people's
problems and if we do it the right way
we get the opportunity to put a price
tag on it
man I love it hey you got to get your
tickets to grow a video live so you can
hear Chris speak and connect with them
he's gonna be hanging out at the
conference he's just a vault of
incredible knowledge but if people want
to connect with you where can they find
you online
and of course we'll link up to your
books and other resources well I'm at
Chris Ducker on all the socials the two
channels I use the most without a doubt
Instagram and now YouTube you'll be
happy to know Chris Ducker comm you
preneur comm and he'll just Google me
I'm a personal brand entrepreneur if I
don't own the first page of Google then
there's a problem I love that a final
word of encouragement - as an
entrepreneur you know some people
listening some are in their legacy years
they build businesses some are just
starting and entrepreneurship is a
roller coaster and you've been at the
highs and the lows can you just kind of
close this off with some wisdom kind of
encouragement for persisting through
every stage of entrepreneurship look the
fact is that it ain't in the easy
journey man you know there have been
nights where I have laid awake as you
have probably have as well worrying
stressing crying sometimes and then
there's been times where I'm jumping up
and down like a 12 year old schoolgirl
you know and just love in life right the
fact of the matter is on big big
believer this particularly somebody
who's all about personal brand and you
know empowering other people to take the
steps forward they need to be able to go
ahead and do likewise with their
community and I will say this be
uniquely and unapologetically you all
the time because the world really truly
honestly does need what only you can
bring to it I don't care what industry
you're in who your competitors are or
who you think they are it doesn't matter
just be you all the time what happens is
your market like a magnet the right
people were coming into your ecosystem
and at the very same time you will
reject the people and repel the other
people away they're the people we don't
want in our ecosystem so just be you all
the time Wow personal branding Shawn
that was such an amazing podcast and it
made me realize I need to get to work on
my personal brand even more after
listening to that with Chris yeah I love
Chris so much and you know what's cool
about that episode and Chris himself is
that you know when it comes to personal
branding
sometimes like I think it gets a bad rap
you think of personal branding you think
oh yeah those Instagram influencers that
are just all about themselves and all
they do is work with companies that they
don't really believe in or whatever but
we're really seeing that no personal
branding is for every business owner
every entrepreneur and khrysta such an
authority to teach on that I mean he's
launched multiple businesses had had
huge successes huge failures now he has
almost like 300 employees and he's
running multiple different ventures and
so I think he's just such an authority
on the fact that it doesn't matter if
you want to be a course creator coach
consultant kind of network marketer
personal brand entrepreneur or if you
want to be like one of our other think
marketing podcast guests and grow a
video live speakers Roger Wakefield
who's got a plumbing business in Dallas
he's got a team but he understands the
power of personal branding and what's
happening in his business is distinctly
accelerating him past the competition
because they're ignoring personal
branding I'd say this think marketing
podcast community if you ignore personal
branding it'll be to your own detriment
in payroll
especially in this decade it's the era
of all of us needing a personal brand
our reputation and so yeah I love Chris
and I'm so pumped that he's gonna be
speaking at growth video live this year
yeah I cannot wait to sit in Chris's
session take notes because he's gonna be
teaching more about you know like you
said how he's been growing these
businesses and really had a scale yes
and also remember that here at the think
marketing podcast we don't just listen
but we take action you know information
is okay but execution is where things
really begin to happen so write down one
of your next steps like what's the
takeaway for you is it to really think
about the questions that Chris Ducker
outlined what prom do you solve who is
it that you help those types of things
and to get clear maybe update your
Instagram bio your chant YouTube channel
about page maybe tweak your strategy put
something on paper put it on your
calendar and let's get some results
because hey we're committed to helping
you get results but you have to take
massive action to do so and while you're
writing that out we just want to shout
out one of our think marketing community
members who left a review on the
cast you know you can go right now to
Apple iTunes and submit a review and so
we're gonna read what Daniel wrote today
yes Daniel said this please do yourself
a favor and subscribe to this podcast I
have been a longtime subscriber of think
media and the value you get from Sean
and his team is incredible you could
easily spend thousands and thousands of
dollars on other courses and classes to
get the same value they provide if
you're looking to uplevel your business
this is where you need to be Wow thank
you so much Daniel that is an amazing
review
I love reading all the reviews that
you're leaving here at the think
marketing podcast and if you're not
already a subscriber and you don't know
we're showing up every single week you
can subscribe right now on YouTube if
you're watching this video or on iTunes
or anywhere that you want you listen to
your podcasts and we would love to hear
from you in the comment section below
let us know what was one takeaway that
you got from this video and we cannot
wait to see you in the next episode
peace